[Music]
mama mama saw Michael Michael mom Akuma
mohamed elmeshad
mama cool - anatomical sigh it's friday
[ __ ] yes it is the birds and
chirping the Sun is out the trees are
[ __ ] happy the squirrels are jumping
up and down
you've powdered your balls you fumbled
with the flag you wiped you [ __ ] you
had your oatmeal you're set and ready to
go you know who's stopping you nobody
only you can stop you gotta suck us cuz
it's Friday [ __ ] I'm at it to the
Cherokee Casino and Oklahoma City with
my main man Steve the [ __ ] sir - no -
with the [ __ ] Indians you know how we
do it you know how wait those
[ __ ] but I'm worried about you
[ __ ] studying are you ready are
you ready to go I'm damn like these
[ __ ] know who's running [ __ ]
I got a ton of tumbleweeds today I got
rascal og from Peretti I still got my
blue cookies I gotta pick them on the
way to perennial og you know doc I'm the
man of many reasons you know I'm saying
you gotta be prepared you're always
gonna be prepared because you never know
what could happen I could [ __ ] happen
I'm saying earthquake there you are well
my only do you know what I'm gonna do
I'm hitting this pipe line I own the
[ __ ] reservation you know I'm saying
anyway let's try this rascal og mmm it's
got a pungent little taste to it that
infuriates me with this hand and body
high go [ __ ] yourself Lee give me a
[ __ ] break
I love mr. squirrel - squirrel his days
hanging out of the tree just minding his
business trying to get a [ __ ] free -
my Uncle Joe I don't blame him
[ __ ] I'm born out of here I could get
[ __ ] washing stone with a small combo
and I put them understanding
flappers was tremendous last night my
sets get stronger by the day for the
frock an hour
I appreciate you [ __ ] helping
me build this little set together so we
can let the rest of these [ __ ]
know who's really running that [ __ ]
car we came you know same door over
there jumping up and down doing colonel
commercials everybody thinks they're huh
but Uncle Joe is over here getting power
where we down like Charlie of the bush
you stand around walking around
meanwhile Charlie's in the bush and
getting stronger you understand me you
know what that means you gotta get to
what every [ __ ] day you're
agonize gonna [ __ ] you up
we're gonna
or the clowns of joey clouds of
happiness it's [ __ ] Friday I'm happy
for you [ __ ] always remember
I'm with you you're with me and they
wanna be with us but they can't because
look - [ __ ] salad of a family
understand me [ __ ] these [ __ ] let's
do a little blue cookies - that was the
blue cookies Joey what the [ __ ] let's do
a little that was rascal
I love this little pay top tailor I
could have with you the [ __ ] mornings
that's it now we got to [ __ ] people up
see what this is [ __ ] real motivation
you think I'm gonna give you a scripture
from the bike well here's my scripts you
suck my balls that's the scripture for
the [ __ ] day you leave the house that
can suck my balls and go through your
psyche and when people looking at me
like you didn't a cup of coffee history
your vision it spells suck my balls okay
I can get your [ __ ] thick you got two
legs and two feet get it yourself
Hopalong you know why they don't take
[ __ ] from nobody
you don't take waters you gotta go you
gotta have this one thing they give
orders balls I'm saying aka Tony Montana
aka Scarface aka my model they're gonna
understand me you know that means
[ __ ] la la la
that's the black hand
basal smoke the best get your lungs
going you know I'm saying
anyway we have the week together you
know we did two podcast whatever we did
some [ __ ] shows in town
Tuesday night up at the [ __ ] possible
Meghan working on material next week
Thursday Friday Saturday next week
listen if you're real and you're in
Denver why all mean whatever the [ __ ]
ever you live in Kansas getting that
[ __ ] truck now and head to Denver but
you know what people Oh Dee last week on
Mt
the last time I was in Denver to [ __ ]
people obeyed I'm smoking [ __ ]
bollocks that never happens but that's
the [ __ ] inspiration I give
[ __ ] bring it to the end bong
hits I'm worth that waiting get excited
he I'm saying getting memories of
[ __ ] anyway
I love you guys you know that you know
we have a good week together we flop
around on my Uncle Joe is a perfect
Miami Joe yeah my taxes cuts up cuz I
got 19 [ __ ] nephews
besides that man that said it's been a
good week and we're looking forward to
another one a way to stay healthy this
week a way to keep your eyes open over
the weekend you know you know no he
wouldn't know a scope not my getting
shoved or why am I [ __ ] hear it would
get shot and you're like why am I here
anyway for this [ __ ] stoop anyone you
know exam
I met have done Oklahoma to Indian
Reservation
and I'll see you [ __ ] would
dwarf uh compact what do a periscope
from the reservation myself who Steve
Simone I love you guys be safe to his
paid they do what you gotta do
hey if he had a bad week next week guess
what next week will be better you know
life as well make [ __ ] surely between
the reefer law heart and the ball sack
we pull all together he had the church
and I'm saying and it's that [ __ ]
simple I love you [ __ ] be safe
today keep the eyes open give your
mother a hug hug the cat and I said
swing picked out of respect because you
only get one shot at this [ __ ]